foreign
[Applause]
this morning on the dish Edgar Duke
chase the grandson of the queen of
Creole Cuisine chef and restaurateur
Leah Chase she passed away back in 2019
but her Legacy lives on in Duke's Big
Easy Eatery chapter four it's called but
to understand his new spot you have to
go back to his roots
today we're coming live it doesn't take
long to catch on the chapter 4 is a
family affair three cousins working in
tandem
in the kitchen Gavin Gaines is executive
chef well you got a beverage director
Eve Heidel behind the bar that's
beautiful gorgeous I might need you to
be my uh cocktail designer Doug Chase
pleasure and Edgar Dougie Chase IV
running the show chapter four is a
celebration of the fourth generation the
fourth generation of chases coming on
board to lead the charge it's a simple
but elegant dining room featuring a
large bar outdoor patio and walls
adorned with African-American art we
still want you to get that fine dining
fill but in a very relaxed setting in
the end it's the food reeling in the
customers
this golf shrimp is really delicious we
sat down to make a plate of our own so
when you talk about all the beautiful
Pantry that we have here in New Orleans
and Louisiana we try to Showcase all
that great stuff here there's
and crab fried rice
you keep talking about that crab fried
rice you created that I did you know we
are known for jambalaya down here right
which is a play on Joel off rice but I
said instead of jambalaya let's let's on
our beautiful blue crab that we have
here in Louisiana Citrus glazed salmon a
top pan seared asparagus a fried Twist
on Oysters Rockefeller and spicy
smothered okra is there a new New
Orleans Cuisine that is being discovered
here or is it really a
leaning in on the time-tested Traditions
I think we're leaning in on to Our Roots
we're celebrating everything that we
have here locally that's why I said
Creole Cuisine is the All-Star of all
Cuisines because what we took was the
best of each and every culture that
brought something here and made a
Cuisine out of it for for dessert
there's this densely Rich cheesecake
drizzled with his Grandma's favorite
Berry glaze the perfect match to a berry
mint rum cocktail called Leah's Garden
it tells the story of her working in a
strawberry pie that's right I love it
Duke's Original career plan was Finance
but after getting his MBA we all have
degrees in so many different fields but
we all find our way back home and home
is the restaurant he set off for
culinary school at The Cordon Bleu in
Paris confidence is the key that I think
that school taught me but none of this
would have been possible without his
family Legacy or that of his grandmother
I like to cook every day a legacy baked
into his DNA we grew up doing everything
waiting tables busting tables cashier in
the kitchen but I got stuck in that
kitchen and I just saw the love that my
grandmother had just looking at the
stove and commanding it and I I fell in
love with the kitchen right then 70
years ago Leah Chase morphed her in-laws
Corner Bar and sandwich shop into a
classic Creole dining room featuring
white linen tablecloths topped with
delicious food surrounded by walls of
black art through the years it was a
safe haven for everyone from Freedom
Riders seeking Refuge to blacks and
whites secretly meeting during
segregation it's also played host to New
Orleans biggest Street party
still does with each offered to Beret
goers in its wide open backyard parking
lot
but Duke's generation has expanded the
family business to two eateries at Louis
Armstrong International and chapter 4 in
downtown New Orleans as African-American
restaurant tour there's much more that
we think about than just Hospitality we
think about Community First we think
about the impact of our surrounding
neighborhood for Duke that means
bringing back the African-American
Museum in Treme a vibrant business
community in the 50s blighted by
construction of the interstate and later
Hurricane Katrina and this does that
Revival process of bringing this
neighborhood this community back we're
talking about African-American
businesses we want to bring those back
good to see you a lot of generational
businesses don't make it
why are you they understood how to
create that family connectivity we
didn't miss a birthday we didn't miss a
Christmas we didn't miss our beach trip
they created such a close-knit family
between me and all of my cousins to
understand that there won't be a
squabble as we continue this Legacy we
know each and every role that each and
every one of us needs to play the food
outside and everybody's cooking
Ministry of a family that Revels in its
ability to give back we kind of keep
going for that next Generation to set
the next bar for us so if we're not
growing and sustaining what we have
shame on us as the fourth generation
and and that fourth generation's already
seeding the fifth generation to tell you
they are a tight knit well-oiled machine
don't ever bet against the chases but I
have to tell you this mama right here
this is called Leah's Garden I already
tasted oh it is delicious it's a
rum-based drink with Leah Chase's famous
strawberries her story
as a kid she loves strawberries so much
she used to pick them
is part of her job that's where she
initially started her farm to table as a
little girl so strawberry is really a
big part of what they do at now Ducks it
looks so good